I have a dream and how the Lord
helps you to realize the biggest
obstacle was to decide, that is, it is
very difficult to decide, I realized that I
can change my life and we
have a historical chance it will finally become
the country that we all dream of
metal others need you  no friends
nobody loves us
I portal 2 expensive cars I sold my
apartment I sold my business
I wrote in a blog that everything I
become is Sarah monitor lizard
the day when the sanctions were imposed it was
August 7, 2014 I realized that I am changing
my life and open to dreaming  does not
open with the goods of the company in Russia,
you can produce
cheese and which are produced in Europe,
you can’t import Belgorod, now a
bulldozer is driving at the border that crushes
gorgonzola, which it can carry from
Italy and this bulldozer is my ally
because while it crushes gorgonzola at the
border,
how the state closes me with a shield
here is my competitor then I can't
compete before the imposition of sanctions I
had a good time getting into business  then there was an
apartment near moscow where maybe they also lived
then i found cheese in the list of sanctioned
goods
apa
workers of the cheese factory live here
most of them are refugees from Donetsk
it used to be part of ukraine now
it was there two years ago the
Donetsk people’s republic was formed here their flag is
difficult to compare with those heroes
who fought for Russia for the Russian
people in the Donbass and died, I believe
that I am investing small
efforts here anyway that allow
us to strengthen our country. The cheese factory
is called Russian parmesan because the
production of Russian parmesan and
Russian mental is its goal
, unfortunately, a
complete copy of parmesan I  I can’t make
a very difficult situation with milk here, and
according to Russian sanitary standards, I don’t
have the right to put a copper boiler
and cook cheese in it, that is, parmesan grilled
ramen tyler, they are all Larisa in copper
boilers,
I just wrote a letter to the State
Duma Vladimir, far away Vasilyeva, this is
Ros  would lift from the ban with  now we
produce Istra cheese, in
fact, berka is simply important, they can’t
pronounce the language of berg, therefore, with its
medical cheese, we
cook it in Limburg, this cheese is very famous,
even Pushkin wrote its relics, we cook
here the village,
this is my bedroom, a small room
here, I sleep, but each  in the morning when I
wake up, I see the model of the future company,
and I admire it, look at the
barn of hay storage
, someday there may be hotels, even a
stable, I look at it every day and
go to the flock to implement it in small
steps, but every day at night I have a
terrible dream  one is also a
terrible nightmare and I wake up I
start to shake with small shivers
I don’t know what to do I dream
that the sanctions were lifted and everything would
end if obama merck or the
cameras were told that you now have sanctions
for 15 years I was under the next week of
memory  put the bronze one in full growth
with a head of cheese in their hands, the three of them would have
kept
me now, there are big hopes that
san  actions forever because they
say return Crimea to Ukraine and then we will remove everything,
they ask Crimea no one will
return it is impossible how and it is possible how
how
it will not do anything like a ruble to chop off a little for yourself
and I wrote a letter to vladimir vladimir
putin when I opened the old army  my
dream was for the president to come here
because the Crimean patient is
pouring out with echoes, a cheese dairy farm is also opening
and I have a gift for him
I always wait for him personally
licks the head of a bear cat for this cheese
which he ate when he worked in Germany in the
KGB he was a scout this  shop with
strictly arnie
here we sell our cheeses and bargain
my mom and what will happen next I don’t know
we can take everything will end and everything will
come back again no matter how I don’t want it I
really want to help our country sell
technologically this is the lack of x
logical preparation of the problem
therefore, I really want that there
were a lot of such cheese factories in Russia,
you can only six such 6 thousand
such cheeses  understand
power well, in order to finally become
the country that we all dream of
as a big unified Russian state
[music]
a